seconds did you ever think you would
make it I feel I'm so I tast Sweet
Victory I know this life for me yeah why
would you bet on Goliath when we got bet
David value taming giving values this
world of entrepreneurs we get no value
to ha run homie look what I become I'm
I'm the
one hit a freestyle Tom fantastic
episode 329 home team we got a bunch of
stories to cover with you lots going on
Nome his uh odds in Las Vegas of
becoming a president went from 44 to1 to
12 to1 why would they do that Las Vegas
doesn't like to lose money Adam's a big
you just revealed me these numbers
Adam's a big money betting Trump guy H
Vegas guys Nome fig the the world
figured out the formula for cleaning up
homelessness within a week have she come
visit your city oh you going to do that
with your kid if your kids don't clean
your room you're going to say hey guys
she's coming listen it's listen moving
forward that's it yeah it's a very good
parenting tip for Vinnie right there so
and then at the same time the rock goes
on Rogan they had a good conversation
saying friends from both sides who
support Biden and Trump and then Joe
says you have friends that support well
no it's just you know so we'll talk
about that with the rock do you want to
see him run
and then there's a speculation of a
civil war going on in Daily wire Ben
Shapiro used the word disgraceful some
twe Tweet stuff we'll show that and uh
is it just a difference is it on Ben is
it on Candace she was on Tucker
yesterday Tucker asked the opening
question about what happened between you
and Ben maybe we'll talk about that
market wise Ken Griffin billionaire sees
Miami possibly replacing Ready New York
City as the financial capital of the
world this is a guy that's worth a good
amount of money and then outside from
that Chicago ready for this story this
one of my favorite stories I've read all
day okay Chicago is so unpleasant that
migrants are fleeing back to
Venezuela that's a real story a real
story oh my God that's a real story now
x x jingping was seen having
dinner with three people Tim Cook Steven
schwarzman and Elon Musk okay
interesting din she was it's a pretty
heavy dinner I mean you you a dozen of
oysters how you going to split it like
between four people it's a bit of a feud
but we'll see what happened there we'll
talk about that and then but every once
in a while we have devastating news to
share with the audience I I typically
don't like to have the podcast be a
downer but I think we have to sometimes
give the news uh Barbara stren said that
she would leave the us if Trump becomes
president yeah absolutely I knew you
were not going to be happy about it I
don't want Trump just hang in there just
hang in there and then us continuing
jobless claims to rise to highest in
almost 2 years and then retail sales
drops in October for the first time in 7
months the clearest sign yet that
commercial real estate is in trouble
when you see this chart it's absolutely
absolutely insane when you do see this
chart and yesterday I had a three-hour
sitdown finally we made it work with the
son of the Majesty Rasha Muhammad Rasha
palavi and r palvi Prince was here
yesterday we had a three-hour
conversation all I will say is there was
some things revealed in that three-hour
conversation that when the Iranian
Community sees worldwide everyone's
going to be talking about this one this
thing goes live it should be going live
later on today if not tomorrow once we
have it done you will see it but I can't
wait for the Iranian Community to see
that it's going to be pretty wild it's
going to be pretty intense one of my
favorite conversations I've ever had in
my lifetime um phenomenal so I can't
wait to share that with you but having
said that before we go into these
stories let's go to our sponsors first
go forward
Rob in the financial industry since 911
the day before 911 and I've owned stocks
bonds mutual funds real estate crypto
gold you name it I've owned it but the
one thing that's very important part of
my portfolio all these years is gold I
love having a percentage of my network
in Gold that I have access to in case of
many different things that's why we
chose to work with our new sponsor
American Heartford gold if you have
retirement funds that you cannot afford
to lose American Harford gold will ship
physical gold or silver directly to your
door also if you have retirement funds
that you can't afford to lose now is the
time to call American hardford gold a
precious metal dealer you can trust they
have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on the link in the
description or call 866939 6984 again
6984 okay fantastic Rob are we good are
we back on okay sounds good let's get
into a couple of the stories here let's
start off with the first one here Rob if
you want to play this clip with G uh and
and by the way the comments Biden made
about G being a dictator and the
reaction to the audience is pretty wild
I say we start off with uh if you have
the the Ben Shapiro clip let's start off
with that first on what happened with uh
daily wire this clip was shown it was
going viral on Twitter and there was a
tweet from Candace Owens and then I'll
let you read the whole thing and we can
have the conversation about go and play
this clip yes the question is about
Candace Owens I think her behavior
during this has been disgraceful without
a
[Applause]
doubt
disgraceful look at the girl's face on
the bottom right her sophistication on
these particular issues has been
ridiculous it's not F sophistication
it's ridiculous everybody can see the
moves she's making and the things that
she's saying and
iable wow yeah and what's he referring
to P like what what what did Candace
position she's taken and and now if you
want to Rob if you want to go to the
tweet that uh uh it's easy to find if
you just go to one of the tw Twitter
accounts and you go all the way to the
top you'll see the exchange between both
of them the one where she says she'll
step down he should she he basically
says she should step down first put some
words about uh you know the difference
between money and God and faith and all
that and she he retweets it so I don't
know if you're going to be able to find
it from there you'll find everything
else uh on the bottom and there was a
back and forth and it not necessarily
was the uh it should have been something
handled privately Rob if you can't find
it I'll find it myself here let me let
me get it for you and I'll text it to
you uh here let me see did you get it is
that the one okay there you go okay so
yeah you want the response to this yeah
you'll see the response to this Rob
we'll find that blessed are the
peacemakers for for they shall be called
the children of God blessed are they
which are persecuted for righteousness
sake for theirs is the Kingdom of Heaven
blessed are ye when men shall revile uh
uh uh you and persecute you and shall uh
say all manner of evil against you
falsely for my sake no one can serve two
masters either you will hate the one and
love the other or you will be devoted to
one and despise the other you cannot
serve both God and money 14.1 million
views on that tweet Christ is King he
retweets that okay his retweet I don't
know if you have that Rob it's it's
tough to find because there's been so
many tweets since he tweeted that but
you should be able to find it and Pat
that that quotes from The Bible saying
that you know she wants peace right they
want as much yeah so then he responds
and Candace if you feel like T that
taking money from daily wire somehow
comes between you and God by all means
quit like what does that have to do 23
million views yeah okay and then she has
another thing that she says after that
and she comes back and says something
else uh responding to him and then
there's this exchange and then she's on
Tucker yesterday talking about this and
Tucker asks who's the boss is he your
boss is he this is he that and says look
for five years we've had all these
different differences between each other
and he's had pretty much every position
that I've had uh you can play one of
those clip with her and Tucker rob you
can just play one of those clips in the
beginning I think he goes right into um
yeah Rob just pick one of them Rob just
pick that one is fine just yeah there
you go and commanded him to stop saying
that the Earth revolves around the
sunward shut
up you're about to have another
descendant actually yeah 40 40 weeks but
I was not missing this I was so excited
I'm honored to be here well so it's is
it a little it's a little weird to see
your look we all get things wrong I
certainly have gotten a lot of things
wrong I think it's fair to be attacked
for getting it wrong but if you get it
right and it's proven that you got it
right and three instances it has been
been proven that you did on the biggest
issues of the day shouldn't the people
who attacked you apologize and shouldn't
someone at least put out hey Ken Owens
was right about I don't think it's that
I think what tends to happen is they
have too much
ego there's a clip anyways there's more
to it but when you're seeing this time
what do you think about the so back and
for between her and uh Ben Shapiro two
Brands is it a big deal is it not a big
deal it's just locker room talk you know
and then Ben's coming out saying if you
don't want the money you can leave you
can quit uh the right Behavior what are
your thoughts Pat you and I have been
involved in business business for a
while and I've had the privilege to work
with you in a business that you founded
and one of the key laws not laws but one
of the key tenants of a healthy thing is
is basically you have home conversations
that need to be had at the kitchen table
home at your kitchen table you didn't
diss your parents to your friends you
protect your parents your parents
protect you and these kind of
conversations should have been at their
office or on the phone by themselves and
putting in out publicly you know that
that that doesn't work and I think Ben
was the one that started it Ben disced
basically if you want to call him the
co-founder okay if you want to say
Jeremy's really the CEO that's that's
fine but he dissed her first in public
and then she tried to respond I thought
in an elegant way and then he goes over
the top all the way to quit if you want
to if you want to go then by all means
quit to me that was just really uh over
the top these conversations should be
had in private and healthy organiz
ations and sorry Ben you started it by
the way here here's a response from her
uh you have been acting unprofessionally
emotionally unhinged for weeks now and
we have all had to sit back and allow it
and have all try to exercise exceeding
understanding for your raw emotion but
you come you uh cross a certain line
when you come for scripture and read
yourself into it I will not tolerate it
she she responds after he blows it open
so she notice she didn't say anything
like that until he blew it open and then
she responded and then Tom what do we
what this is all in regards pack cuz
she's saying the past couple weeks is
because this is since the Hamas
terrorist attack right so I think I
think the disconnect not not even just
with these two human beings I think it's
just in general is that one side is like
Hey listen if you don't think and you
don't support and you don't care like we
do and you can't even question anything
or be caring for Humanity on the other
side it's automatically there's just a
disconnect you know what I mean you and
mind you I've been getting this Flack
too and I'm pretty sure I'll get it if I
ask questions or if I just say guys how
many innocent are like when are we going
to kind of calm down oh you support you
support Hamas I'm no no no no I'm just
asking questions and I'm worried about
the 11,000 12,000 people that were
killed you know how many Hamas I can't
even ask that question so that's that
disconnect because yo Ben is obviously
pro-israel he's 100% he's all in what
was she saying that was so bad
Pat well uh it's safe to say this
relationship ship is completely finished
phito so uh anytime like look we have
conversations debate Dialogue on air but
we have even more conversations off air
big time this like Tom said this is a
this is some something that they need to
have a sidebar conversation off air
they're airing out their dirty laundry
on Twitter that's not going to that's
not a good look for either of them I'm
sorry no one looks like they're taking
the high road if I have an issue with
Pat I mean I I'm looking it this way or
if any one of us have an issue with Pat
we're going to go into Pat's office and
we're going to have a conversation Pat's
going to say this is what you need to do
this how you to stand for hey Pat
respectfully this is where I'm at we're
not going to have a debate with Pat
online no that doesn't behoove any of
our interests so you're putting this on
Candice I'm just saying that there needs
to be respect both ways and you're not
like just we've had many private
conversations okay just like V Vinnie
and I have had many private
conversations just like Tom and I have
many private conversations
we're not going to do it on Twitter it
just seems to be a complete disconnect
whether it was this issue or another
issue cuz this isn't the first time
they've had feuds no you remember
there's been other things in the past on
this particular one what do you think on
this particular one how do you evaluate
it well obviously Ben is as pro-israel
and as Zionist as it gets and rightfully
so that's his position Candace isn't
Jewish she just tweeted Christ as king I
think she's on the side of like she
doesn't want to see innocent people
dying by the way we all should be on the
side of not seeing innocent people dying
whether you're Jewish you should not be
rooting for dead Palestinians and
believe me they're not but whether
you're Muslim Palestinian uh news flash
guys you shouldn't be rooting for
innocent dead Jews so check yourself if
you are but it seems like she's the side
of like can we just kind of figure this
out so dead people won't die and I think
that's a fair point yeah I I think uh uh
Ben
what Ben is doing which you have to
respect Ben is
saying beliefs above uh uh money okay
that's that's really what he's doing
because he knows to take a position like
this and say what you say about Candice
in that video
disgraceful you know when you're a b
there's 50 cameras on you that's going
to go live you know at that phase of
your life you are trained like one of
the first things you learn in insurance
and is you know every time you give a
presentation to 30 or more people just
assume there's a camera on and guess
what everybody forgets sometimes you're
like oh man you know just assume
somebody's recording it so he knows that
that's going to be posted now maybe
right afterward like ah [__] I should
never said that and boom now it's viral
now it's out there now I have to react
to it but Ben is saying guys I don't
cross the line when you want to take a
vaccine I'm taking a vaccine Ben took
the vaccine Y and Candace didn't right
so it's like look
I'm choosing to take the vaccine you do
what you got to do great I'm choosing to
do this say I'm going to have a meeting
with Kanye I will never meet with Kanye
okay no problem and at the same time
look respect where you're at but it
doesn't make for the right business
decision you're making when you're
making it that public okay is a Jewish
Community not more realizing that he's a
100 100 100% pro-israel And Pro Zion yes
that's clear um on the other side as
well when you're dealing with uh a
talent like Candace when you bring a
Candice in if you've been around the
block and you know what her background
is you're going to call and find out
what Candace is all about you're going
to know if Candice is a person that's
got an opinion or not Candace has got an
opinion for God knows how long she's had
it for a very long time no problem the
only thing is I hope these guys figured
out because daily wire is a brand that
should stick around and do their own
thing I hope they this comes gets past
them and she stays there lot oh you
should sign candid you listen man I want
her to stay there I want him to figure
out a way to make it work I want those
guys to work together
make it happen it's a very good team
that they all have a different message
that they bring in but uh we're going to
see what's going to happen there's
certain things you shouldn't air out to
the public and the fact that she goes
immediately and interviews with Tucker
and Tucker just started a media company
uh you know it's kind of like one of
those things where am I uh uh hinting at
hey if daily wire doesn't do am I going
to go with Tucker's New Media Company am
I going to go to rumble do this do that
the reality is both of them are some of
the two two the most talented people
when it comes on to the
they're very good communicators but
we'll see what happened there I'm going
to go to the next story here uh King
Griffin sees Miami possibly replacing
New York City as uh Financial Capital uh
of the world so King Griffin is a multi-
multibillionaire citadel founder uh he
says believes that Miami has the
potential to outshine New York as the
world's Financial capital in the long
run Griffin stated in a recent interview
we'll see how big Wall Street South
becomes maybe in 50 years it will become
brickled Bay north how we refer to New
York in finance he pointed to Miami
growing appeal to financial professional
driven by factors such as warm weather
in the absence of state income tax
Griffin remarked Miami represents the
future of America underlining the city's
potential as an epicenter for finance
and Innovation Griffin's commitment to
Miami includes plan for a billion dooll
Waterfront Tower to serve as citadel's
headquarters as well as various
philanthropic philanthropic
contributions including support for
Children's Hospital sakur initiatives
Citadel maintains a substantial presence
in New York and has plans to construct a
significant Manhattan skyscraper uh uh
Tom when you hear this about Miami
becoming Financial Capital what are the
likelihood of that happening I think
it's very likely because of exactly the
things that he just said do you remember
does any remember how significant San
Francisco was as a financial
Capital people don't remember San
Francisco you go back look at the ' 80s
and and the interconnection between the
banking community and Hong Kong San
Francisco was important San Francisco is
there but you've had people move out of
there uh and people also don't uh
recognize Charlotte you know what's in
Charlotte why is Charlotte so Bank of
America yeah more than just that you wov
yep and it it was it was the regional
center so there is a there is a need to
have more than one you know um if you
think of airlines more than one Hub you
know American Airlines has got Dallas
and Miami um at United in Chicago and
San Francisco I think this is Ken
talking about the emergence of Miami as
an outstanding City and you know in 50
years you're going to be talking about
really the emergence what he's not
saying here that I read about a lot is
the true emergence of Latin America and
South American economies and as they
continue to grow and develop and Miami
down there it's already very
International and diverse especially
with you know wealthy individuals that
that that come from um Latin America
South America Brazil and I think he's
absolutely right we're going to have
another Hub um it's not going to replace
New York but I think we're going to have
another very significant Hub Adam I
agree that it's not going to rep Place
New York born and raised in Miami the
fact that this isn't even a convers
that Miami would be replacing Wall
Street would have been laughable pre-o
laughable you would have been like dude
the only thing to do Miami is club party
club maybe some real estate bro and then
Club some more
like obviously that too but the fact
that we've seen since Co policies
especially in big blue cities like this
we've seen what's happened in La for
sure and then New York for sure people
are looking for something better
specifically the tax situation the
regulation situation the crime situation
Miami shout out to mayor Francis Suarez
and everyone that's basically running
Miami amazing climate for this speaking
of climate I think people are realizing
okay I could be in New York spend
$55,000 for a one-bedroom or go to Miami
spend 2500 bucks for a one-bedroom but
I'm in the greatest climate potentially
in the country other than maybe San
Diego nine months out of the year it's
um it's amazing down here tax Haven
situation where you're not paying income
taxes the problem is a lot of people
come down here and they're like holy
[__] [__] it's Friday it's 300
p.m. kind of got to go uh and then they
just dip out for the day you're not he
doesn't know anybody like that I don't
know anybody like that he doesn't know
anybody some some FKS Miami is is an
amazing City but but specifically he
says maybe in 50 years bricko will
replace Wall Street I don't see it but
they will take some market share away
from Wall Street people are already
doing it him being one of them cuz he
was based on out of where Chicago I want
to say him down there you talking about
Griffin he was in he was in Chicago so
he wasn't in New York but uh love Miami
it's amazing that's where it's at but
it's not uh going to replace Wall Street
what guys everything that you guys just
said I concur yeah and the man from
Miami says it's not going to happen so
we'll see maybe that I said maybe in 50
years happen the next few years we'll
see by the way meanwhile Chicago is so
unpleasant migrants are fleeing back to
venez
favorite story of the day can you
imagine it's got to be so bad that
you're like dude I'm not dealing with
this [__] go back to Communism socialism
and Venezuela here we go thousands of
migrants sent to Chicago from Texas as
part of a sanctuary City policy are
reportedly fleeing back to Venezuela due
to harsh living conditions including
homelessness and extreme weather Michael
castigan a Venezuelan migrant Express
disappointment saying the American dream
doesn't exist anymore there's nothing
here for us that Chicago Michael
Chicago's harsh Winters lack of Migrant
infrastructure and crime issues have
made many migrants decide to return home
the city is grappling with over 11,000
migrants in shelters and 4,000 staying
in police stations damn and Airport some
migrants have been sleeping on wet cold
mattresses while resources and support
are stretched thin despite the
challenges more than 20,000 migrants
have arrived in Chicago last year
seeking Asylum due to unstable
conditions in their home countries and
imagine how bad things have to be for
you to sit there with your kids you
escaped socialism you escaped communism
you escaped pretty much a totalitarian
regime and you moved to Chicago but
Chicago is so bad they're like I'm
willing to deal with a dictator I'm
willing to deal with a socialistic
environment than to be in Chicago Tom uh
well I have a couple wild thoughts on
this and the first is you know obviously
none of these people looted Best Buy and
took an iPhone because if they had
Googled best cities in United States
they wouldn't have picked Chicago so you
ended up in Chicago how how did you how
did you poor souls searching for better
life come from Venezuela and somehow
pick Chicago um first of all and then
second of all it just shows you there's
a there's look there's a it's not
comical for the human suffering these
people with families that are trying to
go find a life it's not comical for that
but it is very
ironic and almost a
caricature of how
this unintended consequence so
congratulations folks you open up the
border and you have all these people
come across and then it taxes the city
the city can't support them these are
human beings they've come here looking
for a better life they came all across
here I didn't now not not legally and
but they were encouraged to make that
that big trik with the pre to people
that came through South Texas and now
look now look you know here's here's
what you get you you have people that
that think it's so bad here and the
cities the city these are stuck we've
seen people matter of fact did we cover
the um uh all the people that went into
the gym at the school in Chicago and had
that major
protest the citizens were freaking out
and saying where are you going to put
them all so the citizens were thinking
about their quality of life their city
and also thinking about where are these
people going to go what are they going
to eat what are they going to do what's
going on and so it's like
congratulations blue cities this is what
you get and now this is the reflection
in the mirror the media won't cover it
that way but this is a direct reflection
of the blue City and the mirror and mind
you this is uh Tom this is from this is
Abbott Governor Abbott from Texas
sending them uh to Chicago how are they
going to get back so now what they have
to make the trk back to Texas and leave
through that Port Aventure I'm I'm
confused how they're going to actually
leave though because they got to make it
back to Texas and then and then what let
this is easier said than done number one
then Adam I'll let you go but this all
comes down to Pat this all comes down to
Alejandro mayoras the homeland security
guy that to this day you guys everybody
out there that's watching YouTube this
this little rat this little snake he's
in front of Congress almost every month
and they ask him all these tough
questions is it secure why are you doing
this why is it an influx all these
terrorists are here everything's
happening why he just Grins and never
answers a question it's done on purpose
just look at that face look at Alejandro
myor is his face this is the guy this is
the guy that is causing all the problems
that all the all these terrorists we've
caught that we send back he can't tell
us how many are here he uh he can't tell
us how many children are missing he
can't tell us he can't answer the
question of the the sponsors that come
and pick up these kids they have no
background checks it's an actual like
influx of just negative crap and this
guy is going to keep his job and he's
not going to get fired he's do he's done
a horrible job and I'm I'm I'm shocked
that he's still employed shocked P have
you seen what uh MTG what uh Higgins and
what Holly have done to him have you
seen these clips or no I love them can
you show one please I what do you mean I
I but this is what pisses me off they
yell at him they check him he just sits
there with a smiley face and nothing
happens nothing happens it's the bark
and no bite that's a Republican party
they always they always get you excited
because you think they're going to do
something but at the end of the day pad
they don't do [__] nothing happens he's
been there for four years it's not a
border problem it's a crisis okay it's a
crisis and wait till you see Tom wait
till you see when it bites Us in his ass
God forbid but I know it's going to
happen when some terrorist [__] goes
down and that guy's going to walk
nothing's going to happen to him and
we're going to trace it back to people
that came through the border and we're
going to figure out where they came from
and isn't it's going to be interesting
how the FBI and the CIA are going to
suddenly give us you know chapter and
verse on how they got here and it's
because they already know that they're
here they already know what's going on
they know that there's sleeper cells
here yeah well let me say something
about this situation it is sad as hell
that if you're from Venezuela and you
make it to America and you end up in
Chicago you're like I'm good bro I got
to go back to to
Venezuela by the way they're the that's
the worst country to be in in the uh
Western Hemisphere with the with with
the potential of Haiti being right up
there but I I don't see them going back
to Venezuela once they made it in this
country believe me they're not fleeing
back to Venezuela you know where they're
going right where Ken Griffin said
people are going down to Miami down to
South Florida my Frank so I have a lot
of Venezuelan friendss a lot of
Colombian friends I have a lot of
friends from South America believe me if
they made it in this country they're
going south they're going to head to
they're head to Miami they're going to
head to Florida they're not fleeing back
to Venezuela that's why I thought this
was a absolute Babylon B article and
it's true but it just goes to show the
downfall of Chicago I remember I'm a
huge Frank Sinatra fan everyone knows
the New York you know it's up to you no
everyone knows that song but everyone
forgets he also sang about Chicago
Chicago ch Chicago tell me the last time
somebody sang a song about Chicago these
days that's the that's I Jay-Z and
Alicia Keys did their you know New York
New York song but did you go party
Chicago Tom I'll party everywhere buddy
just like you like Sinatra did you get
you ever go to the pump room at the Omni
Ambassador Hotel tell us the story Tom
no they still had I'm saying you said
Chicago and them I assume you knew yeah
they still have his uh they still have
his booth there all right all right Tom
we'll check that thing out thanks bud
don't let Tom fool you Tom Tom will King
yeah you know drinking water at 3:00
because he had some wait
filtered filter rolling and my 500 B Oh
I thought when you said time was rolling
and something drinking water that's
exactly what I was talking about but
anyway uh so next the clearest sign yet
that commercial real estate is in
trouble okay take a look at this chart
by the way Rob if you can pull this wsj
story up uh with what's going on with
commercial real estate it's uh it's a
little bit ugly little bit bit ugly but
some people are still holding on and
thinking everything's going to be fine
well here we go um foreclosures and
Commercial Real Estate sector are under
rise particularly in mezzanine loans
making it a significant downturn in
property Market this year a record
number of foreclosures notices have been
issued for high-risk mezanine loans
tolling 62 notices through October more
than double the previous years figures
meing loans known for their High
interest rates have experienced a surge
in defaults due to Rising interest rates
and increasing vacancies these loans
have played a substantial role in
various property TPS including Office
Buildings and apartment why would you
buy a building on a freaking mesing loan
uh interest rates are mesing loans which
typically would be around 10 or 12% in
the past are now risen over 15 damn 15%
making refinancing challenging and
leading to more defaults and
foreclosures Tom I think you know a
thing about mesine loan what do you what
do you think about when you see this
chart here when I see this chart I look
at the bar on the far right for 2020
and I'd like to remind people that
fourth quarter stats are not in that bar
yet and take a look at what's here it's
it's basically what we've seen coming
you know you have you have Three Steps
step one work from home step two return
to office not everyone step three I
don't need all this uh extra square
footage I don't renew my lease I can't
renew my lease I break my lease I get
Bankruptcy Court to erase my lease then
the commercial real estate crisis
started commercial real estate step four
this is local banks and now guess what's
going on now the banks are foreclosing
because hey you didn't you haven't paid
us the payment you've gone 6 months we
wanted to restructure it bankruptcy
judge said restructure it and all of a
sudden boom look at that and so you
could see it was it went up in um in 21
during covid went down in 22 as you
might expect with a little bounceback
and now here we are in 23 look at that
it's almost double excuse me it is
double uh 22 and we don't even have
fourth quarter stats in here so this is
this is the consequence of covid work
from home return to return to office and
economy that is not as good as you as
the stock market would let you believe
it and now we've got uh empty buildings
and banks are for closing look at that
about you know what you're going to get
deals on on uh commercial real estate
right around election time yeah I know
somebody that's uh looking cple couple
deals if you know if some is that crazy
it's bubled over last year and you don't
even have fourth quarter stats in here
I'm actually looking at a property today
and uh we're making a bunch of offers uh
and what we're doing but yeah but look
at 08 though look at 08 just look at 08
after the big you know Big Short the
crash all that goes a little bit up and
then boom flattens comes back down
doesn't get back to the same levels till
2019 but look what happens after covid
you know what that sign is Tom that sign
to me is purely what Zoom did to
commercial real estate that's got
nothing to do with the econom economy
because if it's 08 08 was economy and
look how much economy climbed up not a
big spike but this last explosion to me
to go this Sky okay look at 08 how much
bigger is this year's than 08s remember
Q4 is not in there so assume this is
going to end up being above 80 is that
fair assessment to say it's going to end
up being above 80 Tom absolutely okay
let's say it's going to end up being 85
what is 08 times
2023 what is that let's just call 08
round up and call it 10 I think it's
more like a seven Tom more like seven
okay so that's 11 times 11 times 11
times so so people are sitting there
saying man you know I don't know I think
Zoom has something to do with it and at
the same time these interest rate
mezanine loans you don't mess with
mezanine loans we did once and I was as
quickly as I could pay him off we paid
them off Tom I'm like Tom pay that thing
off we paid it off and went and got 10
million bucks you remember that when we
kind of went through it it can work for
its purpose but you got to use use them
carefully yes you don't use it carefully
you can lose everything you got and we
were able to pay it off as soon as
possible so w I might been oh Rob you're
you're you got you got to you got to
mute your mic so Pat a bunch of people I
mean if you have money then buying a
bunch of this commercial real estate
right now would be smart and just hold
on to it if you can afford it right
there is desperate sellers right now but
there's going to be more desperate
sellers in six to 12 months but but but
and desper so meaning if you have the
money snatch up as as much of it as you
can because that's obviously going to
come back right now it maybe there's a
phrase they use right now and it's right
now you might be trying to catch a
falling knife yeah and you don't do that
you're going to get cut all the way down
I I don't know if we've seen the bottom
yet oh wow I don't think in commercial
realistic you've seen the bottom not in
commercial real estate not up in here no
it's not happened yet not up in here not
up in here Pat you bring up a good point
that 08 is completely entirely different
of what's going on today because in ' 08
the the whole emphasis was these
mortgage back Securities and the toxic
loans and everything that was going on
with that in the big short and everyone
couldn't afford your mortgage everyone
was buying because with the whole Nina
what is it no income no assets and you
just basically strippers were qualifying
for three mortgages and everyone and God
bless them these days it it's it's
almost the exact opposite people can't
get into homes before it was just
basically they couldn't get out of them
or they were getting kicked out of them
but commercial real estate didn't have a
problem back in ' 08 other than Bas
basic basically the bare Sterns of the
world and uh major companies that were
shutting down you talk about how AIG
what was going on with that these days
the whole work from home work from
anywhere it's entirely different
Marketplace is all I'm basically trying
to say the two don't have an actually uh
significant correlation you didn't hear
me mention interest rates or any
economic stats when I was talking I took
you through the steps that was covid
lockdown you know work from home return
to office not everybody returns to
office and then the breaking of the
leases and it's all been corporate and
covid level decisions and the economics
of work from home and zoom coming out of
nowhere you know um to you know impact
impact lives by the way I don't know if
we can pull this up real quick zoom's
stock price all-time high in 2020
2021 it can't be looking good these days
I mean how much is it down we looked at
it before just go to a fiveyear go to a
fiveyear that that one right there look
at that there no go B there's no go at
all plummeted if there's plums by the
way if you would have bought it in 2020
and you got out and basically in a year
man you made some money if you're still
holding on to zoom thinking that's
coming back you're rooting for another
freaking pic Rob hover over 2020 hover
right over 2020 get a number see 66 so
just forget that those three years
existed it's gone from 66 to 63 and just
forget about the climb on Mount Everest
and the fall down what this says though
you know what also this says it's back
to discipl big sucess no no but also
what this says is people are not working
from home anymore that's also what this
says M yeah because this is also sign
just like 08 to 2023 showed the spike
that showed the fact that it doesn't
have to do where it's a market crash to
market crash it's two different games
this was part of work from home now
they're starting to come back home this
also shows you know people are coming
back to work from uh the office so we'll
see we'll see what's going to be
happening there next us continuing
jobless claims rise and highest in
almost two years this is a Bloomberg
story
page
13 uh if you want to go to it folks here
very soon you're going to be able to get
the notes that we go through all the
notes every interview everything we do
you'll be able to get it as well stay
tuned for that so um us continuing
jobless claims rise to highs in almost
two years continuing applications for us
unemployment benefits have surged but
best way to kind of measure this to the
highest level in nearly two years
reaching 1.87 million people in the week
ending November 4th marking the 8th
consecutive week of increases initial
jobless claims have increased to 231,000
during the week ending November 11th the
highest level observed since August
during Rising jobless claims along with
data including a drop in US factory
production and declining home builder
sentiment in November due to high
mortgage rates are contributing to
speculation among traders that the
Federal Reserve may have concluded its
interest rate hikes at the same time you
also see the story see the story right
next to it retail sales drops in October
for the first time in 7 months Tom what
are you noticing here with these two
numbers is that the Q3 party is over we
had a big party where everybody spent
crazy we talked about they used helocs
we talked about that they ran their
credit cards up to a trillion dollars
the party is over the cooling of the
economy is here and maybe the FED has
achieved you know a 3% inflation rate
maybe they have but it was going to come
with consequences and a soft Q4 is here
and the prospect we've been talking
about recession for a while and I know
I've been out there and I've predicted
it was going to be here this year and I
was not correct about that but I think I
am dead right that in the middle of q1
to the middle of Q2 next year we are
going to have an absolute recession
because everything is here and ignore
the stock market there are other
Dynamics going on there but this this is
what I see job claims are sustaining
themselves for um jobless claims in
other words I couldn't find a job I'd
like to renew my jobless claim to see if
I can get State support um and then you
now you also see the uh number of jobs
being built is down and other things are
down so the party for Q3 was over enjoy
the 5% GDP we're here for 1% in Q4 and I
think we're going to see a recession
Midway through q1 Tom let me ask you why
you think you're going to see a
recession you said q1 in 2024 so that's
two three months away right I want so
here's some stats for you because I want
to get your take on this current
unemployment rate in the US is what 3.9%
they just came out with that's not
horrible they want to be under 5% right
that's the sort of Target number un uh
you brought up inflation uh I think the
current inflation rate is low threes 3.3
I think was the latest number they
wanted to be around what
2% stock market doing okay you see
crypto doing okay so obviously the real
estate market looks like a mess right
now but if you look at just sort of the
basic numbers in the economy things seem
to be doing okay so where do you see the
biggest cracks in the economy and why
are you so sure that there's going to be
a economic downturn or recession in the
next few months we'll take everything
you said and just put the word today at
the end of each sentence so right now I
think we're I think unemployment is
going to be back up to 5% um in the next
three months Midway through q1 yeah
absolutely absolutely you the the
layoffs the layoffs are are starting
it's not going to be a wave it's not
going to be a sudden Spike like covid
but what you're about to see is
contraction and you you have to remember
part of the stock market pop that we've
just experienced was layoffs in q1
remember how many layoffs layoffs
layoffs layoffs layoffs and they they
put they put those charges off and then
they artificially profits are up sort of
artificial then you have to look at it a
year later and say okay if you laid off
a bunch of people and your profits were
up Q3 Q4
unexpectedly okay can you do that trick
in q1 what's it going to look like so I
I believe that right now the economy is
in the midst of a contraction and what
will come with it is a slow steady
growth in unemployment culminating in a
5% rate halfway through q1 and a
recession that's just another reason for
me to vote for for Biden and the
Democratic party that's what I'm going
to by the way I'm not I'm not alone here
you read between the lines here I'm not
no I Tom if anybody were going to
believe it's going to be you and and by
the way talking about Biden Rob if you
can show this so here's Biden being
asked the question about G and then
we're going to show the clip about
what's going on in San Francisco
so um first Rob let's start off with the
San Francisco what it looks like by the
way this is when you watch this the
first part I'm going to show you is
China then I'm going to show you what
San Francisco looks like this is China
go ahead go ahead and play this Rob if
you can Rob
Rob Rob play this play it let me hear
this WOW China it's so
clean the streets of China China bro
like I like how they represent with all
of their Flags I I respect I mean you
have to do that it's your country show
that the All Flags it's clean look p is
there any dirt no dirt well this is the
case study like they're saying look how
clean China is this is what we expect
San Francisco W dude to be honest with
you I would love to move to China looks
like she coming in but but and there's
she and you can you can pause it now
folks I'm I'm messing with you that's
actually San Francisco even Rob got
confused Rob I don't that doesn't look
very
Chinese that is you got me Pat China
they made that's San Francisco They made
San Francisco look like China is there
any video of what that street typically
looks like I'd love to see it no well it
used to be disgusting they cleaned it up
they put barriers a guy with a hammer
living on that street he was one of
a yeah go ahead but pay attention guys
not one not one American flag not one
pride flag it's all about China and bro
and Gavin Nome has Pat I don't know if
you saw uh this is Gavin nome's response
they asked Gavin Newsome you're cleaning
this up just because there's some a a
dictator is coming here some leader and
that's your played FKS say oh they're
just cleaning up this place cuz all
those fancy leaders are coming into town
um that's true
why there no because it's true but it's
also true for months and months and
months prior to ape we've been having
different
conversations I know okay so here's my
question this smart politician getting
in front of the narrative yeah but but
ask you guys a question no P it's A8
mile approach why like yeah I know I
live in a trailer park I know that San
Francisco's shitty I know that there
there's poop Maps everywhere but we're
going to clean this
thing look at that go back a little bit
Rob so everybody can go for it what this
is San Francisco before and after look
at the top look at that that's the same
street
before and those are metal things so
homeless people can't sleep they put
that there so no homeless people could
even get comfortable look walls What
happened to the no border wall but I
think I think for the sake of America
she should just do a tour of America get
go to New York go to Chicago come down
to Dallas get some Texas on come down to
Florida let's party in uh South Beach
she just clean up the country where is
the americ outrage where's the outrage
that it takes a dictator to come here
for them to clean up a city that we've
been D begging clean up the the the
homeless the drugs the it's disgusting
so it takes this piece of [__] to come
by the way he's two for two for cleaning
up our streets first first with Co it
looked just like that and now with this
this me we had a lot of riots during
hold on I'm telling you right now this
this relationship this situation should
worry everybody Gavin Nome who we all
know is going to be running for
president we're not stupid he's buddy
buddy with China China's coming in
they're showing their Force Biden Biden
just said two uh guys what did he say
Rob he goes hey Gavin nome's a great
govern I wouldn't mind him taking my
spot watch this watch this pay attention
on what this idiot says
listen want to thank him he's been one
hell of a governor
man matter of fact he can be anything
you want he could have the job I'm
looking for he could do anything he
wants he could even take the job that
I'm looking for meaning the president
the job you have you have the job he
about President you are theid you are
the president yeah but by the way play
play the clip when they ask him about G
and he says what he says and blink's
face you have to see this when he's
answering his Handler like person don't
say that don't say that watch this Mr
President after today would you still
presiden she as a dictator this is a
term that you used earlier this year
look look he is oh my
God he got blinking blinking blinking
blinking go back again go back again
pull it again go back again
Mr President after today would you still
refer to as dictator this is a term that
you used earlier this year
is do that
again presiden she as a dictator this is
a term that you used ear I'll talk he is
oh [__] by you know what that face is
most Americans know what that face is
this is Thanksgiving and your wife just
and you're at the Thanksgiving table got
the whole family around everybody has
sharp knives and your wife just says
something about your mom and
Thanksgiving and Thanksgiving is about
to go into a big verbal fight and that's
you and he's Tom don't throw Kim under
the bus withs okay you have a great wife
go it's pretty crazy even even when he
was sitting across from she and the and
the meeting was coming to an end he his
his he's one of the main handlers
Kirby's one of the other handlers but
then right when it was done the the
their their other handlers are kicking
out all the Press SC and they're like no
no everybody get the hell out you can't
even get to Biden I'm shocked they even
let this question happen but more
concerning is the relationship that
these guys have with shei he shook his
hand their friends this and this just
brings back their whole relationship can
you pull up the Vegas odds for Nome I
think I might it might have actually
been lower than 12 but think about it
while you're doing that I can't wait for
this guy uh but I can't wait for him to
write the book yeah Nome is 12 to1 12 to
he was at
41 44 and we atam couldn't get the BET
guys I'm telling you at home that is the
BET to make is G some especially with
especially with by the way by the way
look look at this even though they show
Haley ahead look where V is at tight
with RFK oh wow I didn't see that wow so
so the polls and only two away from the
santis being at
12 by the way if you want to go there
you're waiting for Rob to pull that up
cuz I've got some new polls too I love
polls New can we address kind of what
what actually some of the tangible
substance that actually happened in this
meeting with China I've I've done some
uh some stuff on this so like obviously
the the dictator thing is going to be in
the headlines and then he was asked
later he did double down on it right
after that yeah but um come on he is he
kind of is a dictator I mean what do you
mean kind of he is he runs the Communist
Party of China and it's you know if you
say anything against the CCP you'll end
up missing look at Jack where's he been
now he's sort of but um I think this is
obviously the most important two country
relationship in the world that it's not
even a question if you want to get into
the substance of what's going on with
China we all know that the CCP runs that
country but uh their core foreign policy
is usurping the United States to being
the global leader and they want to
counter the US and become the uh
dominant country in the world so uh the
the premise of this meeting was
restoring confidence in the Chinese
economy we've covered the whole everr
there wasn't even another real estate
company that they've been basically
under bankruptcy so they basically came
here to sort of smooth out relations in
the US we've seen the debt crisis we've
seen sort of the downturn in the Chinese
economy um but here are the key things
they talk about they didn't he didn't
mention much if anything about trade
relation or even the the debt situation
going on in the US it was all about um
stabilizing just general relationships
they were talking about having military
contact moving forward or uh resuming
military contact uh working on the
fentanyl situation cooperation on that
what do you mean what what do they mean
by working on the fentanyl situation you
guys are sending fentanyl here work and
they talked about climate Adam climate
they did do a little bit of climate they
were talking about new dialogue
regarding AI but most importantly
probably the most important thing they
discussed was the uh conservation of
pandas here in the United States that
was one of the main topics they talked
about over there but they did really get
into trade or investment or anything
like that go back to can you go back to
that cuz hold on what China says right
here this is an ultimatum this isn't a
conversation she says us and China can
only be adversaries meaning enemies or
partners with no middle ground that
isn't a relationship that is either
we're going to fight or we're going to
be cool we can't just be like chill with
each other and Adam this just goes to
show us that China owns US owns Biden
Biden is compromised bro they no no what
do you mean you don't they can fly spy
balloons wherever the hell they want
okay they they can buy land next to
military bases they're buying hundreds
of thousands of acres of land when they
come to San Francisco it gets cleaned up
to a tea and homeless people are
freaking kicked out and pushed to San
Francisco I mean to Sacramento like
China owns US how much more proof do you
need and that's why this relationship is
scary because I'm telling you right now
if Trump gets Trump gets to run and
Trump is the front runner that's what
you need to be scared of we were talking
about uh pandemic to maybe coming to
help zoomo who knows what the hell is
going to be up their sleeves bro because
they do not you think China wants Trump
to come in you're nuts def let me let me
just finish my point here because I
think go a little faster go make your
make your point because we're about to
wrap up okay so but the here the thing
is rather I'm not even talking about
politics right now put politics aside
because that's obviously but this was a
business basically a bizde situation if
you want to look at who was at that
dinner last night it was a $40,000 per
plate dinner and then you can pay $2,000
to basically be a part of the ga you got
Tim Cook Elon Musk was there but he did
I guess participate in the dinner you
have Steven schwarzman from Blackstone
um you have Larry Fink from Black Rock
you have Ray doio sitting there you got
the exec from Qualcomm from fizer from
FedEx from Boeing Mark benof was
apparently there but Mark Zuckerberg
interesting enough wasn't there even
though that this has happened in surgery
he gotur h his name but I think in my
opinion and this kind of goes to you
every single name who was at this dinner
every single name who was basically a
part of this their names should be
disclosed coinciding with this whole
Apec meeting that was going on not APAC
American Israeli but ape the Asia
Pacific the Asia Pacific Rim that was
going on there any name out there that's
dealing with China their name should be
disclosed for sure I'm definitely not
basically saying yeah he can come in and
do whatever he wants I'm basically
saying that I'd rather have dialogue and
relationships with our greatest
adversary rather than being like [__]
you here that doesn't work yeah so
here's the question by the way total net
worth of 700 60 billion billion dollars
was at dinner geez and and take 250 of
it from one guy okay yeah and and Jeff
Bezos wasn't there so it's not like
Bezos was there to add his 200 so take
bezos's two trillion dollar crew right
trillion dollar net worth was there but
here here's the thing so X gets up and
says we can either be allies or enemies
but we can be in the middle how do you
interpret that Tom uh very simply at
this business dinner he said the terms
of being in business with like this
we're a full partner which means we open
the borders for each other and we are
unconstrained and or we're full
adversaries and I'm taking Taiwan and
you want to come do something about it
you know we can we can get there it's
that simple because what he's saying is
tariffs I don't want the tariffs I don't
want the complete um uh impediment to
certain shipments of certain Imports of
certain materials let alone the Tariff
on it he's saying all no restrictions no
restrictions so and he he wants China to
be our unconstrained
unrestrained trading partner to ship as
much as they want in Period and that's
the end of the story so either we are
full Partners like this and get rid of
all this tariffs and stuff or we're full
adversaries pick one but Tom wasn't that
the whole premise of the Republican
party is just free trade Don't Stop
Trade l a fair economics like isn't that
wasn't sort of the whole part of trp but
if free trade is truly fre free and if
currencies are truly balanced to one
another but China has never had a
currency that was balanced and pegged to
the world currencies the dollar the Euro
the pound it's never been pegged to that
it's always been an unfair um economic
game with what happens to to pricing and
so yeah it is unless you're dumping
unless you're you are putting tariffs
the other way so if there's tariffs the
other way good Republican presidents
have spoken up oh oh you're going to put
a tariff on aluminum going that way I'm
going to put a tariff on all the Box
site going the other way yeah I I don't
that's the way it works I totally get
that but I but I wanted to ask him so
Tom with that attitude either
adversaries either enemies or Partners
once we say okay we sign on to this
which it seems like they're going to do
but I think Biden's going to do it then
when they want to attack Taiwan we're
remember there's no middle we're either
with them or against them so what's what
do we do I've made my one point and it's
just another 20 minutes to go and
analyze it but you know like here's
here's what I would say this this is
what I would say with this for me
he's getting up here he's saying what
he's saying great you want to be allies
great um it's either this or that I
actually like the way he's doing it if
I'm if I'm China and I'm in his ear or
if I'm a if I'm somebody that's
processing with him on how to present
this to America he did it the right way
because what he's trying to say is
whoever gets elected next you guys
better not start investigating me for
you
know what happened during
and all this you better not bring that
up CU if you do that we're not partners
of course so now here's the part uh if
America doesn't investigate that then
the American people who don't ask for
that as an important issue are so
shortsighted and so quick to move on
that the only way you resolve any
issue for example think about it what
what what what needs to be there for
capitalism to work
what needs to be there for capitalism to
work in a fair way what needs to be
there Freedom Liberty and debate okay
there's one word that needs to be there
laws okay why do you need laws because
if you don't have laws then there's a
lot of things that somebody can come and
do to bully you for example China back
in the days when they wanted to kind of
start competing with us there's one
reason why they couldn't compete with us
China only had four law schools the
entire country only had four law schools
think about that crazy what the hell you
mean you have only four law schools so
then they started investing into law
schools because they needed to have Law
and Order so when you compete you're
able to go do what you're doing and it's
safe and protected right so what is the
whole concept of Law and Order that
leads to what why do we need Law and
Order to hold people what accountable is
China going to be held accountable
definitely not no but the but that's not
the right thing though they have to be
held account we have to find out what
happens
because and then China says you know
it's either what allies are not fine
let's define allies is it your
definition of ally is it you defining
because you and I can get a husband and
wife can get married and say I want to
be a partner for the rest of my life
okay maybe your Definition of partner is
very different than mine your Definition
of partner could be give me half of
everything you got that's not my
Definition of partner here's what my
Definition of partner is so if you want
to be partners here's what I want you to
do what's that allow every one of our
social media companies to be in
China give access to all our social
media companies that's a definition of
partnership to us yeah if you're okay
with us we want to go out there and
investigate to find out what happened
with Co because I'm sure you want to
know just like we want to know let's be
partners let's partner up and find out
where it was leaked to see if it did
come out you want to be partnered that
to me is what you call a partnership
right so whoever is the dictionary to
define the word partner dictates the
terms if China decides what the meaning
of partnership is it may not be a
partnership to us but it means to them
so but he's playing his cards in a very
brilliant way and by the way one thing
about Biden here's the one thing about
Biden forget about what Biden should say
what Biden typically says off to cuff
and and he correct him himself that's
what really Biden believes in 100% did
you understand what I just said right
there like Biden knows this guy's a
communist dictator but they're going to
go correct him because that's not what
you're supposed to say it's what he is
MH so Biden's not necessarily A
diplomatic uh uh you know uh he doesn't
have the Diplomatic prowess of you know
going out there and just showing his
ability to do that that is specialty um
but we know who this guy and at the end
of the day whoever is able to negotiate
and structure what a partnership means
that organization controls the other one
I'm not comfortable partnering up with a
country and by the way you said
something you said
don't you believe in the fact that you
know La Fair you know let them you know
Republican Nixon is probably where
you're going to let's open up this and
let's open up that yeah open TR but it's
got to be both ways though and this is
not both ways this is not both ways this
is more this way they're benefiting us
is not benefiting from this relationship
as much as they are makes sense the
amount of money on import export when
you look at the how much they're getting
instead of us they're crushing it in the
negotiation X and China should write a
book on negotiation it'll probably do
better than art of the
deal and the reality is they are we
don't want to them to be we don't want
trying to go to war with China
especially a hot War but they're not our
friend this isn't a binary option it's
somewhere in the middle here we're
competitors we're decoupling from their
situation over there they're we're all
about capitalism they're all about
communism and the we're never going to
see eye to eye on this and what was the
whole China 2030 what was that the they
made in 2025 yeah 2025 that's that's two
years 13 months from
now but the uh 2025 is able that but
that obviously was preco but I I we we
can have competition without conflict I
think is really what it comes down to
but they are not our friends so I don't
believe that this is a binary option
that looks like an underage kid working
right there Rob that photo that you got
that looks like a child labor camp which
I don't sure it is I'm pretty sure it is
he's s he's such a good guy that we
should roll up the red carpet from him I
don't trust him at all so Dwayne Johnson
was on Joe Rogan and and they talked
about President you know hey you know he
says you know a lot of people from both
sides are asking me I should run for
president all this is this the part
where he talks about running or is this
the part where he talks about Joe Biden
friends things like that the second one
go ahead and play the clip I was a
kid you could have a republican friend
like it it was no big deal yes it's no
big deal like oh Bobby likes George Bush
who cares who gives a [__] you know you
were a supporter of Bill Clinton he
liked George Bush nobody cared nobody
like [__] you you know wasn't like
you're a Nazi like I'm a what I mean I'm
a Nazi I just want lower taxes Fu what
the [__] are you talking about youing
how did I become a Nazi dude it's the
craziest thing I have friends who
support Trump I have friends who support
Biden I have friends do you really have
friends who support Biden come well no
no no no no here's here's what I do I
have I have friends thank you that's a
good check cuz that's important this is
important context they support the
Democratic party I have friends who are
loyal to the party yes you be loyal to
the party
where where are you remember that clip
yeah with Trump you remember when he did
calling out Trump six years ago four
three years ago no it was during Co
right years yeah exactly three years
where are you and you know I'm like he
was wearing a black shirt or something
like that relax I don't know man you
know you know what I think when I see
this by the way good for him for going
on Rogan
fantastic uh the right place he went to
do that you know the rock is one of
these guys that you love his story you
want to love him you want to love him
you want to support him you want to be
all there for him and but there's one
challenge with the rock you know what
the challenge is with The Rock he wants
the cake and he wants what is that
phrase go have your cake and eat it to
he wants he wants and you can't yeah you
can't do that today because you know so
the whole conversation with crown up
palav when we're having a conversation
yesterday do conversations about take a
position
do you want a job or do you not want a
job so imagine if your father is the
king of Iran okay do you know in an
interview with CBs in 1976 you know what
who they consider the most powerful
leader in the world the most powerful
man in the world his father R sha pal
Muhammad R pal wow by CBS they said this
is this to his face you may be the most
powerful man on Earth
okay you go from that your Son you learn
how to fly planes at 11 years old okay
you're sharp you're smart you're
eloquent you're all that stuff everybody
wants you to run for office everybody
wants you to go back and go be this and
go be the second coming of your dad and
your grandfather and all this stuff the
question becomes what do you maybe he
doesn't yeah maybe he doesn't want to do
it maybe he's got a different plan for
himself right for me with the rock is
you know he wants to keep Hollywood
happy and keep his Oprah Winfrey friends
and all this stuff but he knows deep
down inside he's a republican MH rock is
a republican rock is not a liberal rock
is not a Democrat rock is a center right
guy rock is a pro-america pro-military
pro hard work pro do your thing Pro
protect your family pro- mother Pro
father Pro being a husband Pro being a
good father Pro taking care of yourself
Pro being Clean Pro being organized
these are all qualities of
right responsibility you know give back
he's all that he's got all of that but
he knows if he comes out and says that
he loses 80% of the people that he's
doing movies with and the way he was
talking about running for off you know a
lot of my friends on both sides it's
kind of surreal how did I go from being
a regular guy to not people are asking
me to run for office and all this stuff
it's very surreal it's very surreal no
it's not surreal IR Rock DJ you got
couple hundred million followers man
you're you're you're the most
recognizable face on Earth I think he
was 57% of people worldwide recognize
his face of mind us like a couple
countries he's got the highest rating on
people
that one of the best Smiles in the game
good-looking guy comes prepared showman
entertaining likable but brother if you
want to go into this spa space you have
to take a position you do vanilla's not
going to get you into the White House so
a lot of things that people were talking
to him about they're like well I don't
know about that I don't know about that
I don't know about that I don't know
about that it was like a either he does
or he doesn't want to give his opinions
on it to me he doesn't give me the
feeling of a guy that doesn't know about
that I get the vibes from rock that he
knows he knows enough to have an opinion
on it and he's logical enough to take a
position um but does he want to that's
the question because if he chooses to
run and he runs as a Democrat okay do
you really believe in the policies that
they believe in do you really believe it
or do you feel you want to do that
because you is the question between your
Camp are you having these types of
conversations with the people that are
in your corner hey guys let me ask you
should I run as a democrat or a
republican they're going to run polls to
see what way would he have a higher
chance of winning instead of what do you
want to run for there's these are two
different I don't know if you understand
what I'm saying I got it so you
shouldn't do a poll and say which one's
going to give me a higher chance to
become the president the question should
be what do you believe in perfect boom
boom boom boom boom great if you believe
in this run as a center left center
right run as a this run as a that
instead of you know well based on these
polls if you run as a democratic rock
you will win 54% and you'll beat the
Republican Rock of 46% I think that's
what his campus probably doing I think
so too and and but think about if he
does go to that Democratic route you
know the same people that when Joe Biden
says oh they told me that I can't say
this they're going to be they're
controlling him the entire way like he's
not going to have his own decision he
would make one hell of a leader if he
let a rip and he you ever you ever read
the book Fountain Head or at the
shrug yeah have you guys gone through
any I never read Fountain Head have you
read Atlas Shrug Tom have you read
Fountain Head have you Ellsworth okay so
you know the the one part where the
husband his wife is like like this and
the Mother-in-law are like this well we
need more money to go do this and he
just going to work and doing what he's
doing and he's just sick and tired of
being married to the wife that he is you
you know that scene yeah he's like on a
little hamster wheel kind of thing yeah
he's just running life like that yeah
and and finally he takes a stand he's
like this is it man this is where I'm at
and you know what happens he earns a
respect he really you know there needs
to be a part where everybody's telling
them what to do what do you believe in
man go do that if you do that and you're
straight up about it you're not acting
you're being authentic we will feel it
but if you're doing the acting stuff
where are you you're an actor yeah that
wasn't you really doing that at Trump
you were doing that because WME or CIA
or whoever told you to do so and you're
but by the way check this out when Dana
White talks do you believe it's Dana
talking
100% I can stop you right from there cuz
you could tell he doesn't give a [__]
about your feelings he just wants to let
you know what's up when when uh let's go
through a list of these when LeBron
talks is it LeBron talking or is he
thinking about his agent and all CH and
and China talking when vacuous vapid
empty you can go through a list of
actors you can go to a list of when
Trump's talking who's talking Trump okay
when Obama's talking who's talking
pretty much Obama the I don't know I
don't know who do you think's talking
when Obama's talking I think it's I
think it's half Obama and I think it's
half measured believe it or not I think
it's more Obama Talking than when
Biden's talking when Biden's talking
it's not Biden talk of course it's not
so but but even and I'm with you ask me
about Obama might take it 5050 okay I'm
more 60 I think Obama's talking 60% I
don't think he has a mouthpiece for
somebody else we're on the same page is
not a full True Believer yeah you you
know so for me when when Rock talks not
when he acts he comes out with a movie
I'm supporting your stuff I love his
gear I have his shoes I love his clothes
but when you're talking about
beliefs I'm sitting there saying that's
your Camp talking and I hate to say that
and I would love I would love to talk to
the guy off camera no phones nothing and
just say what do you want to do like
like would love that conversation but
again it's he I'm not sure if I'm his
cup of tea he likes more different types
of conversations but yeah go for it by
the way and you know what week
leadership in that situation looks like
do we remember when Obama was caught on
a hot mic leaning forward into Putin's
ear and said I will have more
flexibility on this issue after the
election of course he was running
remember that he was running Against
Romney and he leans up and says that do
you think Ronald Reagan ever says that
to gorbachov never not in a million
years M oh I'll have balls after the
election yeah I I ordered them I don't
have Amazon Prime but they're going to
get delivered right after the election
I'll be able to do something sorry well
here's my take on the Rock real quick I
think down to his core you're talking
about a guy who had played football at
the University of Miami go kaines by the
way um then he went to the w WWE do you
smell what The Rock is cooking like that
was his base right men football
wrestling that's him 100% but then look
what happens in Hollywood once you go to
Hollywood right you see what happened to
John Cena when he basically said
something about Taiwan homeboy speaks
Mandarin now
flu like he had to give a fullon apology
in Mandarin I don't know how they did
that I don't think that was the Mandarin
dialect that's pretty much what it was
but now the rock he's he's worth how
many hundreds of millions of dollars
now I have the opinion that most people
if not all are for sale okay so hey rock
you want to be worth uh a billion
dollars cool just get into the Hollywood
world you know it's obviously Democratic
left it's woke it's all that it's LGBT
it's Pride it's the lgbtqia cult Mafia
all that but like you're going to be a
billionaire so you got to be anti-trump
you got to stand for this and just walk
the line but it's binary work or don't
work correct so I think he's made his
decision I think at the end of the day
he's probably more of a synergist center
right guy but he's going to play the
Hollywood Game and that's why I don't
think he's doing anything in politics I
think down to his core he is more of a
center center right guy but he has to
play the leftist in order to basically
appease Hollywood you have that video of
John Cena by the way John Cena like the
whitest guy ever speaks Mandarin go
ahead this is this isn't the be no you
can't play this you can't play Rob this
isn't the apology there's one where he's
just looking there it is right there
this is
it
what let me translate let me translate I
so sorry you guys let me translate for
the people at
home can't hear it
though oh my money's gone you can stop
but that's what it looks like when you
can be bought by the money by the way
nothing wrong with that go get your
freaking money but just can't be trusted
but and but here's my thing though like
Okay so Rock I agree with you 100% Adam
no way in hell he's giving up Hollywood
to go be a president or anybody in the
political world but I want to ask you a
question what would happen I want to ask
all you guys what would happen if this
election he comes out the rock instead
of you know the video where he's like
come where are you Trump and he goes
like this guys uh I'm Dwayne Johnson AKA
The Rock with what's happening with the
country with the border with the economy
with the brick of World War II with
everything that's happening I got to go
with Trump what happens to his whole
career everything D plummets it goes
guess what girls are going to come out
of the woodwork and say that he touched
them he's his career his name his legacy
goes to [__] he'll get Russell Brandon
1,000% so guess you nailed it at him
he's staying right in his Lane he's not
getting political and that is it and bro
just do that then yeah say it I would
come out and be like I have no interest
in running for president this is not
what I'm at does make your money yeah
just like Gavin nuum said he's like I'm
not I'm not running for president Gavin
is running for Gavin we got you but this
is the this is the clip that you were
talking about Adam where uh he new's
hair is in bed oh this is the clip that
you were talking about Tom this is the
one with the Russia where he goes no no
no no yes it is no that's not Putin no
it's not Putin but this is Putin's
number one we we'll go we'll go after
the stuff afterwards you can play that
if you want to play go ahead this is oh
and it was I'm sorry it wasn't Med was
my
last after my election I have
more and I transmit this information to
yeah okay yeah I'll have more leeway oh
oh we Mike still oh that's weird are you
people are still here oh yeah we still
got politics though come on yeah but
that's come politics my ass you don't
say that you don't think those
conversations take place off camera
every single day in every single country
of the world we just caught it on a hot
mic 100% but so he's in bed with Putin
that's what that I'm not going to he's
in bed with Putin he's basically saying
I have more wiggle room after the
election every candidate would probably
say something like that I don't trust
wiggles or rooms atam so you can go the
hyperbolic comment and just say gosh
these conversations happen all the time
and you can be correct I'm talking about
what I my point was leadership you're
not going to see if I'm Reagan I'm not
going to have a conversation with him
I'm GNA talk to Putin direct and I'm not
g to say that that's that's leadership
you got to know who you are what are you
defending what are you changing what are
you creating that's why you run for
office and you have to have that as
authentic passions of who you
are preach Tom what are you running for
president then Tom I'll vote for Tom no
I'm saying I look at candidats I want to
know what are they going to defend what
are they going to change what are they
going to create that's the three
things that's the way the cookie
crumbles you have any no I'm not here to
argue with Tom I'm just saying that you
don't think those types of conversations
happen all the time I mean come on I say
listen for the sake of tradition of this
week I say you guys fight I say like
let's go bro you want to step out TW
tweet each other like stuff tweet off we
we're much scripture from Old Testament
you give some script from New Testament
and let's kind of go through it that's
right we're we're already good to see
how much more aligned we are I don't
want you end up to be on the show and
just be What story do we have that we
haven't covered anything else outside of
that I'm going to wrap up so we'll go
tomorrow morning uh this was a short
quick podcast we wanted to do with a
couple stories to cover with you
tomorrow we'll be back at it again we
got a lot of Stories We haven't covered
9:00 a.m. uh uh uh what's it called 9:00
a.m. uh home team tomorrow 9:00 a.m.
tomorrow morning okay take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye
bye-bye